is russia stealing ukrainian grain and
selling it abroad
this video shows lorries in the southern
ukrainian city of militipole heading in
the direction of russian-controlled
crimea
thought to be carrying this vital
resource
a sky news forensics investigation has
tracked several ships moving grain out
of ukraine
this isn't just one isolated incident
it's happening on a large scale
using marine traffic data we followed
the route of one of those russian flag
ships the mikhail nanashev believed to
be carrying grain to turkey where it'll
be unloaded
it's track traveling north through the
bosphorus on the 21st of may having come
from the mediterranean
the following day its onboard tracker is
switched off its last recorded position
is here in the black sea
but the same ship is located in
satellite imagery stopping in sevastopol
port in crimea the peninsula that russia
invaded and annexed back in 2014
satellite imagery from the same day
shows it next to silos being loaded with
what analysts say is grain
two days later it's shown again now with
its cargo covered
the ship turns its tracker back on in
the black sea the next day on the 27th
of may it travels through the bosphorus
past istanbul where this video was shot
and for a few days it passes through the
mediterranean before docking in the
turkish port of iskenderen where it's
seen here the cargo on board now being
unloaded at a talk that receives grain
several days later the ship travels back
to istanbul and is filmed traveling
through the bosphorus now notice how
much higher the ship is in the water
indicating it's no longer carrying its
load
location data shows the mikhail nashef
travelling back towards the black sea
its onboard tracker going off again at
this point on the 11th of june
ukraine alleges documentation from the
ships is being faked to say the grain is
from russia not ukraine
kiev's ambassador to turkey is under no
illusions about who's behind this
there's most probably
russian intelligence are responsible for
that because they are physically a
military intelligence about controlling
the situation on the land
occupied territories and the scale of
the soul and grain this they mean the
amount of money they gained from the
millions of us dollars
russia denies selling ukrainian grain
abroad while turkey says it is
investigating
last month we gained rare access to
odessa port on ukraine's black sea coast
before the war had exported millions of
tons of grain around the world
its grain elevators now stand idle ships
moored up blockaded by the russian navy
russia is preventing millions of tons of
grain reaching those who desperately
need it while evidence powers up showing
it is stealing ukrainian grain and
selling it abroad or using it to bribe
poorer nations to support it over the
war
dominic wagon sky news